remember when the news was made like
this
the internet did away with that of
course only it didn't stop there
after years killing print journalism now
the Internet is coming for digital
journalism
- last week online magazine the pool
became the latest digital publication to
go into liquidation freelance writer
Marissa bate lost her main client the
reason for the job losses line the thing
that may print publishing not so very
different to its digital equivalent you
look at this printing press in this bit
of dead tree and it feels completely
different to what we read in our phones
but in business terms it's almost
exactly the same because of these the
ads classifieds Holmes motors that's
what front of this industry and it's
that business model of putting ads in
front of readers or in front of TV
viewers that the Internet is really
killing you still get ads online of
course more than ever as this chart
illustrating advertising shift from
print and TV to digital shows but
instead of going to online news outlets
the money's heading straight to Google
on Facebook
someone watching closely is Magritte
first ire Europe's powerful Commissioner
for competition I think when you look at
how things have changed over the last
ten years you have de facto end up too
ugly you're the competition commissioner
you start something you're concerned
about something you're looking into we
have some questions yes being asked
about some of the advertising but the
pattern the general pattern is quite a
quite clear trend towards Google and
Facebook taking all the advertising
revenue and yet above the printing press
we find something that shouldn't
possibly exist a brand new local
newspaper making money from ads there's
a real danger if we lose
community newspapers that we really
undermine the democracy of this country
and I think people need to have trusted
sources and newspapers local newspaper
websites are among the most trusted
resources that the local community can
go to some good news at last but as
every journalist knows it's bad news
that runs Rollem on top Sky News